So you could have used either the population standard deviation or just the 2.71
for standard error. So our x bar is 40. We have 40 minus 2 times 2.71 as our
lower bound, and then 40 plus... 2 times 2.71 for our upper bound, so that comes
out to 34.58 and 45.42. So we're pretty sure, that if everyone started using the
Beaber Tweeter, then the mean of the population, and the mean of the
corresponding sampling distribution of size 35, Would be between these two
values. So our distribution could be anything from here, centered at 34.58,
where this value 40 is still within that 95% range. Or to here centered at
45.02, where our mean is still within that 95% range. This interval from 34.58
to 45.42 is called the 95% confidence interval for the mean.